hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
from Monday June 17th 2019 what's going
on how are you how are you everybody
happy belated Father's Day to you happy
belated Father's Day to you will woo woo
happy belated Father's Day to all the
dads who probably didn't get [ __ ]
it now people ladies Father's Day to
everybody I'm actually recording this on
Father's Day so I have no idea what my
father's day is gonna be I think it's
gonna be a good one I'm doing the
podcast earlier because my lovely
family's taken me and my father-in-law
out for a nice [ __ ] steak dinner over
there killing the cows that I said I was
gonna try to stop eating I was gonna eat
a little bit less you know and then what
he doing he fish the fish are all going
away and then I read in that Howard
Stern interview and in Rolling Stone
dead his white cell count I forget if it
goes up or down I forget what it was and
they thought he had cancer and they were
gonna give him chemotherapy and it
turned out he was eating too much
[ __ ] fish and he had all kinds of the
yet although this [ __ ] mercury in him
they almost gave him chemo so I what
what can you eat the [ __ ] can you eat
anymore
I don't know I just try to eat I try to
switch it up I try to hope 1 carcinogen
knocks out the other carcinogen that's
in my food and then I just do the
elliptical that has been my game plan I
went down to the cellar last night
Saturday night say I did one spot at the
original then I did the fat black
pussycat upstairs and then I downstairs
I did the village underground and I came
walking in right and I had already eaten
healthy and I came walking in and the
seller has really healthy food the olive
tree upstairs so I'm like okay
worst-case scenario I'll get like a
chicken kabob little thing he what do
you call that that super chopped up
[ __ ] salad not tahini that's the
sauce not Tiki Marcela I don't want the
[ __ ] color I forget what it is I was
gonna get one of those salads and then I
walked in emanate ordered out for Joe's
pizza and they had four delicious large
cheese or pepperoni [ __ ] pizzas and
they're like have a slice have a slice
I'm like I can't I have an acting gig it
sucked that's what kills me is I'm gonna
have to try to cram all my pizza eating
you know I went off the rails when the
Bruins Lost's
the Stanley Cup game 7th but is even
that I only have one slice but they had
all this great stuff and I laid off I
laid off I stayed with the waters and I
proceeded to have three the most fun
[ __ ] shows I've had in a long time
and I'll tell you there's all the great
things I get to do in this business I
swear to God
nothing nothing nothing is more fun than
doing stand-up comedy and trying a new
bit and having at work there is nothing
in this [ __ ] business of shoe as they
say that it's more [ __ ] satisfying
and exciting than that and I finally got
the abortion thing to work
I stopped opening with it so I just got
it I moved it down a little bit so they
just saw I was sort of silly and then I
went into it and I just had three
[ __ ] great shows the night before I
was at the Westside comedy club had a
great set there and because I'm gonna be
in Pittsburgh here in a few weeks and I
got to come with all the new [ __ ] even
though my special hasn't come out yet I
feel like I did Pittsburgh on this run
and I don't want to just in case
somebody is a repeat customer you know
what I mean I don't want to come back
with the same [ __ ] is what the [ __ ] I'm
saying so and being out here in New York
is really making me want to come out
here every summer for a couple of weeks
and just do a bunch of spots take my
wife to a bunch of cool stuff so at some
point I gotta walk my kiddo IO whenever
I go to New York I always have to do the
walk across the Brooklyn Bridge so I
still have to do that and there's a
couple other things but I'm laying off
the smokes now I got four days laying
off that I'm gonna try to go back to how
I used to be which is I smoked one every
two weeks and I was beyond looking
forward to it
it's just with Father's Day and my
birthday people bought me a couple boxes
of cigars that I'm kind of like well
what am I supposed to do here I don't
want these to go bad right I mean I got
a smoke them probably hand a few off to
my friends is what the [ __ ] I should be
doing but uh I don't there's always
something you got to be working on in
your life they made my life is like
[ __ ] perfect right now I got a great
acting gig I'm in New York I can do
my stand-up my family's here I'm playing
drums the weather has been nice it
hasn't gotten ridiculously hot yet it's
just been absolutely [ __ ] perfect and
today I'm gonna do my podcasts early and
I'm gonna hang around and I'll watch the
rest of the US Open I watched a little
bit yesterday watching Rory and all
these guys and [ __ ] tiger and Phil
Mickelson and all the younger kids who I
don't even know who the hell they are
I just got it I was just like you know
what it's so hard when the NHL and the
NBA stopped those fast-paced thinks that
all of a sudden just like you know pull
the emergency brake and try to get into
baseball you know but so I go I'm gonna
go even further into a slowed down sport
and I'm gonna [ __ ] it I'm gonna watch
golf
because then baseball will seem fast
paced so that's what I did yesterday I
laid on the couch I watched it I took an
old man nap I think I fell asleep on
that guy was trying to he was in the
rough and there was a little [ __ ]
flower and there was a bee on it and he
didn't want to swing the club and kill
the bee you know which back in the day
they would have just blasted right
through it and you wouldn't have known
because there was no HDTV I don't think
PETA had the [ __ ] strength that they
have now but you know the bees are going
away so I think that guy you know he was
thinking environmentally you know
granted he swung the club and killed the
[ __ ] flower what's going to happen
today
vegetarians realize that plants feel
pain then what are they gonna eat if all
of a sudden we come up with something
that we can actually read their thoughts
like if that flower was just sitting
there yelling at the beat don't leave me
don't be like that guy god damn it jack
dojo do this in 48 hours telling the bee
not to leave don't hand him the gun over
which by the way in all of cinema had to
have been the worst cop moment ever when
he gives his [ __ ] gun away their
destiny I don't know anything about
police being a policeman but there's no
[ __ ] way you've turned your gun over
when he has a gun on a hostage and
there's another cop there without a
[ __ ]
but anyway so the the [ __ ] flowers
probably sitting there yell at debate Oh
lay me down joke do it he takes off and
he's just sitting there wanting to run
in a can't this guy just swings a club
back all the other flowers trying to
look the other way like I'll you hate to
see it date the [ __ ] see it but you
know something a lot of nature is
getting eaten in life there's a lot of
[ __ ] horrible ways to go you just get
eaten you know I remember thinking
getting eaten by a lion would be
terrible and now when I watch it it's
not that bad you know I've seen a few
people get eat by Tigers and [ __ ] they
just put them once they grab you around
the neck which is immediately you just
pass out you know just like in the UFC
except it's like the [ __ ] tiger level
strength it's [ __ ] over although
there was one guy who was sort of
kicking at another tiger and this
pathetic he tried to sneak into the
[ __ ] zoo how much is his ooh you know
30 40 bucks and where he scaled and
jumped over the wall was the [ __ ]
tire layer Enclave what the [ __ ] do they
call those condo [ __ ] areas right and
he [ __ ] landed hit the [ __ ] didn't
look first did not look before he leaps
because he was doing something illegal
and he landed and he was in the [ __ ]
he was in the [ __ ] tiger enclosure
and they don't have any guns over there
I'm sure they brought that up at one of
those [ __ ] Second Amendment is that
one of this is that the Second Amendment
the right to bear arms you stay you're
right now there was America he shot that
[ __ ] tiger on the face cuz that's
what everybody would the gun sounds like
kidding of course they could have used a
gun that would have been a great time to
have a gun although the world is
overpopulated and that guy was a [ __ ]
[ __ ] and he was doing something bad so
that's a very hard thing that's that be
a hard thing for gun owners you know cuz
they'd be like that sumbitch got what he
deserved
alright Family Values you go to the zoo
you pay to get in you
sneak over if you're gonna sneak over
always make sure you have a whole weapon
on you I learned that from Ted Nugent
all right then on top of that the guy it
happened to wasn't quite so I don't have
any feelings for him whatsoever there I
get enough stereotypes in there about
gun owners I always like people trying
to make them out like they're all a
bunch of [ __ ] morons you know it's
like well then wouldn't they be like
[ __ ] accidentally shooting themselves
all the [ __ ] time and don't even say
they do okay they don't that's just like
the helicopters that I fly where
everybody says they're [ __ ] dangerous
because a bunch of people dying and most
people don't most people don't all right
and the people that do do dumb [ __ ] and
you know that's it that's how [ __ ] it
works if you do dumb [ __ ] you're gonna
have a [ __ ] problem all right I'm so
you know what I'm doing is I'm just I'm
filibustering I'm waiting for my [ __ ]
me to get some of the the materials here
that I need in order to complete my
podcast there's usually some sort of
advertising and of course you guys right
into the podcast I might have to hit
pause eeeh how much time have I done how
much time have I done oh my god only ten
minutes in gee willikers gee willikers I
feel like I [ __ ] talked about
everything already
I mean God's sakes I have 50 more
[ __ ] minutes to go here oh I took my
wife and kid to go see a movie yesterday
I went to go see that what does that dog
movie Patton Oswalt's in it Kevin hot
isn't a Tiffany Haddish all these great
comedians are in a dog movie 2019 what
is it called
Oh for god sakes the advertisements only
right outside my window
I should have wrote Kevin Hart in there
Kevin Hart dog movie
the secret lives of pet fart - yeah we
wouldn't go and saw that my daughter was
so excited right I was saying I was
telling her that I was gonna go I go I'm
taking it to a movie tomorrow and she
goes popcorn and a movie
it's her favorite thing in the world she
just sits there with this giant bag of
popcorn you gotta watch a toddler though
cuz they're like a puppy they'll eat
until that literally their [ __ ] belly
explodes so I had to keep taking the bag
away from her until she had like not not
too much popcorn and then I gave her a
couple of M&Ms and that was it and she
sat there and she enjoyed the whole
movie so thanks to all the people that
worked on that you know being a little
bit in the animated world I can't
imagine how much [ __ ] work that is
and how long it took you guys to do that
so thank you for the great hour and a
half two hours of [ __ ] entertainment
and other than that all I did I just
walked around I didn't smoke any si gars
I was was a good boy last night and I
was rewarded with good [ __ ] spots
thank Christ so let's go let's go to the
Google News this is what I do while I
wait for my while I wait for my new [ __ ]
to come in here let's go to Google News
as opposed to the mall where news that I
was getting and all right Donald Trump
is up to his usual [ __ ] this is the
funny thing ever Trump warns of a market
crash quote market crash the likes of
which has not been seen before if he
loses the 2020 election but economists
are worried he's causing a recession of
his own he's causing it don't the
[ __ ] [ __ ] who really run it cause
it United States President Donald Trump
on Saturday warned without evidence of a
massive market crash if warned without
evidence of a massive market crash if
he's not reelect ydynt when t 20 dude
have you ever seen a guy who loves to
scream fire in a crowded movie theater
like this guy the Trump economy is
setting records and has a long way up to
go he said however if any
but me takes over in 2020 I know that I
know the competition very well there
will be a market crash the likes of
which has not been seen before Keep
America great do you realize how [ __ ]
selfish and irresponsible that is to
tweet something like that yeah I think
there's a market crash coming anyways I
could say that without [ __ ] knowing
anything about it all I know is they
just they just keep building these
luxury high-rise [ __ ] apartment
buildings everywhere I go every [ __ ]
city I go to this just cranes and cranes
and cranes building more [ __ ] I don't
know where all of these people are gonna
go now this is conspiracy theory that
the people that will really run the
country are trying to drive everyone
into the city now if they were building
even remotely affordable housing I would
believe that but what these [ __ ]
luxury high-rise [ __ ] things are
doing is they're actually forcing people
out of the city
I told I've told you before about the I
always loved bringing this up like some
of these buildings that they're building
in New York City they are so high they
actually have to penny a shadow tax
because they block the Sun from certain
parts of the park and the trees and the
bushes and grass overs all [ __ ] dying
and then what kills me is they are
actually up into the airspace commercial
airspace bravo airspace work for
LaGuardia I don't know if it's Newark or
what I think it's laguardia's airspace
and it would just blow my mind that if
you bought the penthouse and on a cloudy
day when you can barely sit outside your
window you are in the same airspace as
jumbo jets [ __ ] flying by I mean I
just don't know how the [ __ ] do you
relax at that point that's when you go
downstairs to the lobby and and asked
what the Wi-Fi is down there and you
just wait for that marine layer to
[ __ ] burn off all right what am I
talking about buildings in bravo
airspace at this point all right this 15
minutes I'm gonna [ __ ] just hit pause
here and I'm gonna wait till I get all
the
as I need and I will finish on with the
podcast alright alright I'm back I got I
got your questions I haven't gotten the
read yet this is what happens when I
[ __ ] try to do it so early but I was
just sort of going around here to the
Internet and this thing here was talking
about a of Vladimir Vladimir Putin Putin
is Steven Seagal says arrested critic
Alexei novel II novel knee hundreds more
for taking part in an anti-corruption
protests Russian authorities arrested
Alexei president Vladimir's Frasier's
critic along with hundreds of other
protesters who took to the streets
following the arrest of a journalist the
mass arrests on Wednesday came after
thousands of people participated in an
unauthorized rally in support of freedom
of the press and investigative
journalism journalists Ivan Golan of who
was arrested on drug charges but later
released after the government that there
was no evidence he committed a crime
[Music]
it's unbeliev I you know how familiar
does that look I mean that's starting to
be what it's like over here I know it's
a little more extreme but like you can't
[ __ ] protest they let you you got to
get a permit to protest and then when
you do they have you [ __ ] you down
like 20 blocks down and away from any
sort of press coverage all our press is
[ __ ] seems to be owned by [ __ ] 10
different people I don't know I never
understood the whole [ __ ] end game of
these [ __ ] who just want to run the
world it's like and then what what are
you gonna do what the fight why can't
you just [ __ ] just is it that hard to
not be an [ __ ] this is coming from an
[ __ ] I just don't [ __ ] understand
why you can't listen to you people I you
know I do get it on some level where
most people are mouth-breathing morons
and it's either you gotta kind of have a
firm hand I mean was kidding no we're a
bunch of children all right I can barely
read I get sleepy when I try to read
in-depth [ __ ] so I mean I shouldn't be
running anything I'm
glad that there are people out there
doing it but I guess Michael I guess my
question is is is that the only way to
[ __ ] do it is the only way to run a
country is to have secrets and tell
everybody to shut the [ __ ] up and
destroy anyone that questions your
authority because regardless of the form
of government capitalism communism
whatever I don't even know enough of um
socialism that seems to be what they all
do they all do the exact same [ __ ]
thing you know the illusion of choice
the illusion of freedom you know what I
mean you are free sort of I don't know I
don't know how it works miss there's got
to be a [ __ ] day he gets it they call
these guys saying I'm a corrupt piece of
[ __ ] yeah yeah I got to go out and go
[ __ ] arrest this guy then you know
people are gonna be slapping him around
and stuff and then well then what you
supposed to sit there eating a [ __ ]
pheasant or whatever the [ __ ] rich
people eat you know they always eat some
weird bird can of chicken that's like
too common they always have to have like
a [ __ ] goose there's something you're
just gonna sit there and do that while
these guys have [ __ ] torturing
somebody because they had the audacity
to say that maybe you were a little
outside the lines a few times you know I
think that you could actually if people
thought you were corrupt you could
actually stay in power we just admitted
it to up in like you know what yeah I
got a little out of line a couple of
times but you know if you look
historically this is how it's done what
say we change that so what are your top
complaints about me I will work on it
and I'll free all these journalists and
from here on out I will welcome their
criticism then I will try to be a better
leader now at that point even the
[ __ ] people you jailed well they
probably don't trust you at that point I
would think would be willing to give you
a second chance I just don't understand
why every single [ __ ] time you gotta
go as Patrice O'Neal used to say you got
to take out the [ __ ] goat in put it
on the back of people's necks and just
start [ __ ] kicking the [ __ ] out of
everybody
it's got to be yes sir is there a
country I don't know I don't I didn't
get that vibe when I was in Iceland you
know there are countries out there where
I don't feel like they necessarily have
to do that but uh who knows
who knows it's it's depressing it's why
I don't [ __ ] pay attention to it it's
all it's above me I don't understand why
I I'll say it until the day I just do
not understand how war is still legal
I understand somebody literally comes in
and [ __ ] attacks you you got you got
to fight fire with fire but just as far
as just like hey we want to do this what
we're gonna do that all right now we're
gonna try to kill more of your people
then you can kill of ours and whoever
kills more people is right that's the
best we can do I have a wireless
headphone set but we cannot go to war
all right let me read some of the reads
here for this weekend these aren't the
advertising this is I'm gonna go
straight to the [ __ ] emails here my
19 year old daughter introduced me to
you about three months ago my 19 year
old daughter introduced me to you and I
am a big fan what I love about you is
that my daughter and I can enjoy your
comedy together and I get to enjoy the
references that bring back my childhood
I'm 52 well I'm 51 there you go look at
this everybody thinks I don't have any
sort of a female demographic look at
this I got a 19 year old kid introducing
me to her mom perfect and you explain
the references to my daughter this week
Phil Niekro and Ken Stabler if you're
going to read a book go back and read
Jack Tatum's they call me assassin I've
already read that it will remind you
just how brutal football was yo yeah the
NFL was you know I read that one I read
they call I was in Hollywood Henderson's
book I read a lot of them I read these
that's the type of [ __ ] I read I read
the autobiographies of everyone who
wrote one in Guns and Roses that's the
kind of reading I do and then every once
in a while I'll actually do something
that's actually I'll read us like a you
know a difficult book that isn't a book
about some famous person's life but that
can stay the one is definitely on my
radar
in fact I enjoyed reading in between
setups on the movie so much you know
what I might go to [ __ ] at amazon.com
right now see if I can if I can [ __ ]
find that book I'm gonna I'm gonna lip
see Ken Stabler book Ken Stabler I gotta
order now before you [ __ ] buy every
copy Ken Stabler autobiography Yeah
right there we go come on what do you
got there oh it's just called snake and
you kidding me that's all it's called
snake badasses by Jah the legend of the
snake john madden does the forward or
something look at all these [ __ ]
books right yeah snake by Ken Stabler
four dollars in nineteen cents why's
Amazon 1721 because it is that the drone
charge what the [ __ ] come on snake the
legendary life of Ken Stabler the first
in-depth biography when the most
talented and infamous legends to play in
the National Football League the life
and times of pro football's first
bad-boy Fame
he's not the first bad boy famed Oakland
Raiders quarterback Ken Stabler
ken the snake I wasn't that lovely I'm
gonna [ __ ] here's another Raiders one
cheating is encouraged a hard-nosed
history of the 1970s Raiders I mean who
the [ __ ] doesn't want to read look at
these books oh my god I found my part of
the library countdown to Super Bowl how
the 68 69 New York Jets delivered on Joe
Namath's promise this is all you do is
you just start clicking on these [ __ ]
things all the way Joe Namath beyond
Broadway Joe Cousins of wills Johnny
Unitas Don Shula and the rise of the
modern NFL oh my god I would read all of
these these are the great Bob a Bob
Griese book
big fella Babe Ruth in the world he
created this is Johnny Unitas
not for long the life and career of the
NFL athlete the 1969 Baltimore Colts oh
my god Raymond Barry this is this is it
right here all these people like me
saying I don't like to [ __ ] read I
will read I you know who's read all of
those [ __ ] books at least the
basketball ones was Bill Simmons when I
read his book on the history of
basketball Jesus Christ that guy would
be like it's like in Rick Roby's in Erik
fern Stan's book like you know they
wrote a book all right men dying young
hey Billy statwhore figured you'd find
this interesting it shows how men are
dying in their prime and an increasing
rate 92 thousand a year twice as many as
the Korean and Vietnam wars combined
which is funny because almost
three-quarters of all health and
lifestyle related progress products are
marketed towards women proves many of
your points happy Father's Day well I
think it's also marketed towards women
because they're allowed to take care of
themselves you don't I mean guys have
like a fear of going to the doctor and
you know what that fear is it's because
you haven't gone and so long so if
you're a young guy I recommend right now
getting a doctor going and get a
physical you know
ninety-nine point nine percent you're
gonna be alright and you know if you're
not it's great you went in because then
they can [ __ ] maybe save you but if
you go in early it's like back in the
day like the getting getting tested for
HIV aids the first test was [ __ ]
brutal because that was your entire
career everything you [ __ ] did and
you just sat there sweating bullets then
the next time that get tested like
[ __ ] once a year and then you're only
worried about maybe one or two incidents
you know they always lie to yourself I'm
always in the way of going I mean I mean
you [ __ ] up right all right
so I highly recommend that all right
there
real gender gap in heart disease because
I'm a guy I took a poll at the recent
family barbecue heart disease who has it
worse men or women I asked the answers
came quickly my mother-in-law and
sister-in-law said women my
father-in-law arms crossed said
confidently men
my mother-in-law remembered hearing
about how heart disease affected women
more than men during the February
American Heart Association Go Red For
Women I got to be honest with you when I
hear people dropping a heart attacks
it's usually a guy anyways apparently
the message wasn't heard by the men is
this family gathering they were moved by
stories of men fathers brothers friends
they knew who died from heart disease we
are taught that facts should trump
feelings evidence should trump anecdotes
and at first glance it would appear the
men are in touch with their feelings it
is the mission what it's a mission of
advocacy organizations like the
eh-eh-eh-eh to raise awareness charts
like this one are wildly dissonant and
used in countless presentations on the
topic I don't can't even read that word
well I thought this was going to be an
easy article I don't know what they're
talking about the graph demonstrates
that over the last few decades the
number of women dying from heart disease
has been significantly higher than men
from heart disease in the year 2000
alone the gap is the most impressive
with 70,000 more women dying than men
the problem with the chart is that it's
completely misleading mortality in the
case is best judged by death rates that
take into account age and population at
risk dude I got to be honest with you I
know a number of guys who have had heart
attacks and who died of heart attacks
I've never known a woman to die of a
heart attack I don't know that's weird
I feel like women get breast cancer and
guys get heart attacks that's kind of
and we get [ __ ] prostate cancer that
seems like they they actually what was
that person trying to just say the
opposite in the email because it seemed
like they would argue on the other side
I have no idea all I know is I have a
doctor now and I get [ __ ] checked out
that's what I do because I had a buddy
of mine who was 49 years old getting on
an elliptical was in better shape than
me and had a fatal heart attack so and
he was never overweight or anything like
that so sometimes it's just like you're
you know your genetics and then also
like the [ __ ] that's in food who the
[ __ ] knows who the [ __ ] knows
sometimes my paranoia I think that they
let you know it's usually just because
of money but I and I but I feel like the
politicians let what happened to our
food supply happened because they knew
that they couldn't tell people to just
stop having as many kids so we can taper
off the population so maybe they're
taking things into their own hands I
have no idea all right Apple store I bet
they have a beautiful [ __ ] organic
garden for everybody at a certain level
of power eating all old school [ __ ] all
right
Apple store hey yo William billboard you
may want to think twice about taking
your Apple product to Apple store well
too late now I recently saw this video
and thought you might find it
interesting just something to consider
Apple Genius Bar is scamming customers
what they didn't charge me any money and
they fixed it now I gotta watch a
12-minute oh oh oh they're talking about
their labor charges well I'm glad
somebody put this out here because they
were on their best behavior when I went
there I showed up and I said William we
have you down we will call you in six
minutes and I said I listened to music
and right when I was worried did they
forget about me as two people came over
what's the problem they figured it out
they'd [ __ ] handle this [ __ ] in 20
minutes it was over I'm never clicking
on anything ever again and the malware
was gone it was really bothering me that
was on my [ __ ] to the point I didn't
even use my laptop for like three days I
was so [ __ ] pissed it's like I don't
watch porn anymore
I don't booze anymore I've totally
cleaned up my [ __ ] life trying to you
know be a better person here and then
yeah I still end up getting a [ __ ] if
I was watching porn I'd be like well you
know I played the game you know what are
you gonna do I mean you know you're
gonna get to a knife fight you're gonna
get [ __ ] cut what do you think is
gonna happen but I was sitting there
being a goddamn Saint and I still got
one very very upsetting
all right let's read another one here
what do we got here okay single girl
help love when the ladies write in all
right hello Billy Matchmaker I'm a long
time female listener in need of advice
if you Arnie I have a few minutes to
help out I'm a 35 year old woman living
in New York City I own a two-family
townhouse in Brooklyn oh you crushing it
she goes on I'm a lamp I'm a landlady
that's awesome good for you that thing
will pay you your whole life I have a
curvy and voluptuous yet healthy size-12
figure I don't know what that mean I
know you're curvy you're a bigger girl I
hit my home gym on the regular and go to
therapy once a week I got great
relationships with supporting and loving
friends and family I absolutely love
music and cooked pretty well I run my
own small business that is successful
and as you can tell I have a great sense
of humor but listen he's your podcast
since 2011 all right what's not to like
I've done a lot of work on myself over
the years to break habits of dating guys
who are fun in real life but on paper
have Peter Pan syndrome and are
essentially adult children I'm ready for
the real thing
there you go I was that guy for a long
time the problem is I'm having a hard
time finding the real thing I work in
the fashion industry the majority of my
colleagues are straight women or gay
guys any men after that are married or
23 years old 23 year old interns I've
asked my
men and women in success relationships
if they could play matchmaker for me but
none of them trusts that got their guy
friends enough to get with me and not to
not screw me over
it's hard anyways because I'm focused on
a healthier lifestyle I'm not interested
in meeting a guy at a bar at 2:00 a.m.
no you're doing all the right things
you're right guy is coming you staying
single you're working on yourself
I would suggest before you get through
the rest of this is getting some sort of
extracurricular activity that involves
interacting with healthy people some
sort of sports league thing maybe some
sort of volunteer work just somewhere
where you gonna hopefully meet decent
people just get into that circle because
you're not going to meet a decent guy at
2:00 a.m. in a bar anyways I'm not in
AAA or 12 steps I just like to wake up
early and not have a bloated face online
dating is okay but most people on here
are just looking for hookups absolutely
I'm not approved by any means I've had
more than my fair share of action living
in the dorm room that is NYC so the
question is can you suggest ways for in
New York City for me to meet guys who
have their [ __ ] together who are looking
for the real thing perhaps if one of
your listeners hears this and is
interested no absolutely well I think I
gave you the suggestions that of a 51
year old man who has not been single in
I don't know 15 years so I do know that
when you decide like I am NOT settling
and I'm just gonna stay single until the
right person comes along that's when
most people meet the person that they're
supposed to be with you don't force it
you don't force it and you know you go
through the holidays alone which is fine
you know hang out with other single
people and there's like there's a friend
then you can also be you know other
parts of your life do well like your
business because you're not distracted
by it I thought we were going out and
I you know and that's what it sounds
like when you're with the wrong person
when you're with the right person like
hey I thought we were going out tonight
you've gone [ __ ] yeah hey let's do it
I actually like you well good luck
good luck you're doing all the right
things you're still young you still in
your prime you got the whole [ __ ]
thing ahead of you crushing it yeah I
would try to you know look at Time Out
New York and [ __ ] like that there's no
there's things that like decent people
do and I don't know what they are
because I'm one of these filthy
entertainers I'm gonna I'm in the
nightclub scene you don't wanna be
around this way okay I'll tell you some
rough one there's got to be something
something going on in the park
you know bus people back in the day who
like let's let's start a rollerblading
group like those people there those are
decent people I don't know I just
realized I don't know where the decent
people are accidentally cut someone I
love how this word has come to do into
the lexicon cucked is like a big [ __ ]
Internet word everybody loves using that
word now hey Billy but [ __ ] the more
soft mark the funnier hey Bill I just
found out about a situation I've become
involved in and would like to hear your
opinion on the matter I'm a
twenty-year-old college student in
Pittsburgh and found myself involved
with the lady during the school year we
weren't dating or anything but she would
regularly come over and we would hook up
the girl is really hot and the sex was
good and all but eventually I broke
things off and started seeing a
different girl and seeing a different
girl okay every now and again this girl
would hit me up to hang out but we never
did because I was interested in another
girl and even though I'm no longer
seeing the new girl this this other girl
still hits me up from time to time
however I recently found out that this
broad had a boyfriend in the entire time
oh the entire time we were [ __ ] Jesus
Christ I know someone who got this [ __ ]
kicked out of him one time because of
that they had no idea had no idea and
was sitting in the car with her and this
guy just [ __ ] yanked him out and beat
the [ __ ] out of him of course it's his
fault right
I kind of feel like a piece of [ __ ]
knowing I was [ __ ] someone else's
girl yeah but you didn't know because I
wouldn't willingly hook up or even hit
on a girl who was in a relationship I
would just like your opinion on whether
I should feel bad about having sex with
the girl this girl dozens of time and II
think I should reach out to the guy to
let him know how much of a horror for as
I would love to hear what the lovely Nia
feels about this as well thanks and go
[ __ ] yourself well there's no reason for
you to feel guilty because you didn't
know you were doing anything wrong
reach out to the guy that that's your
decision I would I personally would just
walk I never try to get involved in [ __ ]
like that because you know what if the
person doesn't believe you then they
know who the [ __ ] you are and then
you're dealing with some [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ] I don't know I have no idea I'll
let you make that decision yourself but
you shouldn't feel guilty because you
didn't know if you go back and do it
again then you should feel guilty all
right that was an easy one okay what
else we got here ninety minutes haven't
done yet oh Jesus another 22 okay my
wife and I have been together for 13
years ten years married in almost 11 10
years married almost 11 all right
whenever we argue uh-huh oh this is wife
wife things wife things my body is
aggressive what wife thinks my body is
aggressive I don't even know what
anyways hello Coppola still my wife and
I have been together for 13 years 10
years married almost 11 whenever we
argue she accuses me of yelling which
I'm not I sometimes proceed to show her
the difference between the way I'm
talking and yelling she then chain
changes to say that I'm not yelling but
I'm sounding aggressive I don't know
what that means and I've asked her what
does she mean she's talking about your
tone she
that's because I have a deep voice and a
big guy 6-3 to 60 that I come across as
aggressive this pisses me off because I
cannot control my size to me she's
saying if I was a smaller guy with the
same voice I would not sound aggressive
I've gone so far as to argue my point
with a gay voice to sound less
aggressive this that's you did that
because this pisses her off even more
I've walked away so I don't get pulled
into any arguments this pisses her off
even more I don't know what to do how do
I control something I have no control of
I feel like she just wants someone to
argue with and I'm forced to take the
bait that's what I feel she just wants
to argue then I made to feel guilty for
my size and voice by being labeled
aggressive how do I a not make my large
football player sized body not seem
aggressive during an argument and be
walk away from the argument without
pissing her off even more thanks and go
[ __ ] yourself while dreaming of the
2010-2011 Cup run oh that's what you
meant by coupla s' yeah dude
this is what's going on she is
manipulating the living [ __ ] out of you
to win arguments all right so what you
have to do in an argument is you have to
not raise your voice this is what though
if you want to win with the woman you
have to not raise your voice you have to
you have to say what what they did and
how it made you feel and then you have
to listen to them and when then they're
done yapping okay if they tried to worm
their way out of it and you know that
trying to worm their way out of it you
can't accuse them of it you have to sit
there and say like okay I heard what you
say I don't understand how that pertains
to what it is that I'm saying and you
just stay there and eventually if you
with a [ __ ] adult they're going to
apologize all right
you shouldn't be yelling anyways I'm
trying to stop doing it I've been was
doing so great and I don't know the
stress of being on the road and I can't
go to therapy now I've kind of [ __ ]
I've gone back a little bit but I was
able to see that and now I'm kind of
focusing back on not yelling but
I think the fact that you have the balls
to have done the gay voice to your wife
shows me that you're not afraid of her
and she doesn't have your balls in the
purse so I would just you know I would
talk to her about this while you're not
in an argument I would just sit her down
say We Need to Talk should be like a
half alright and then you sit down and
just say listen when you're in an
argument in a relationship you're gonna
have disagreements okay the way I air my
disagreements doesn't seem to be working
for you so I need you to tell me the
proper way that I I you know so then you
get her to commit if I sit down and not
raise my voice will I then be heard and
not be criticized right so then and then
just play by her [ __ ] rules and
she'll think that she's winning
but then what she's done is she's
eliminated her ability to avoid what it
is that you're saying and just talk
about you know the way you're you you
gestured with your arm how low your
voice are high your voice was and that
takes all that off the table and now you
just have to deal with the point that
you're trying to make and I would give
that a try and hopefully that works and
if it doesn't and she still just finds a
million things to [ __ ] about then I
would consider moving on because you
know who wants to be in a relationship
with someone who's not an adult and
you're just signing up to be bitched at
24 [ __ ] 7 for the rest of your
[ __ ] life and honestly who the [ __ ]
wants that nobody wants that okay and if
you sit down with her and you have this
conversation then the next time you guys
argue if you followed by what she's
saying would not be aggressive and all
of that and she still has a problem with
that then you advance the conversation
of saying like listen this is not adult
behavior okay I'm not signing up I don't
want to if this is the way you're gonna
be every time we have a disagreement
that no matter what I'm doing it's it's
not gonna be about what I'm saying it's
gonna be about the way that I presented
it
then I'm never going to be heard in this
relationship and that's not what I'm
looking for so what do you want to do
say thing he's saying about break up
with me I'm saying if you don't start
acting like an adult I am going to break
up with you
I'm going to move on this is going to
get old okay I know I'm not right a
hundred percent of the time but I know a
good 30 percent 35 on a good month I am
right and I'm just not seeing the data
is not showing that the results here all
right I would go that route I would go
that route all right that's it for the
questions now I'm waiting for the
advertising met the link like three of
these [ __ ] things together all right
now I'm back I'm back with in time for
the reads here good Lord this has been a
real disjointed podcast I apologize
simply safe everybody you know ten years
ago getting home security stunk it felt
like companies went out of their way to
make your life miserable with long
contracts you never knew what you'd pay
and they made your you rewire your whole
home well that must have sucked this was
considered normal then simply save comes
along and totally transforms home
security
they did everything right they built a
better system and they treat your right
simply safe stands up to you unexpected
to the unexpected from burglars to
blizzards to blackouts all the B's they
got it covered simply safe has 24/7
professional monitoring and police
dispatch everything to keep your home
safe it's a PC Mag Readers Choice and a
wire cutter top pick and it one CNET
editor's choice twice not once but twice
and simply safe makes your life easier
there's no contract no hidden fees and
no rewiring your home 3 million people
are protected by simply safe already and
not one of them is locked into a
contract
check out simply safe for yourself visit
simply safe bird comm all in capitals
the Bur part you'll get free shipping
and free returns plus a 60 day money
back trial that simply saved
dot-com so they know that I sent you
simply save bird comm and lastly but not
leastly oh look what it is everybody
it's all stamps calm stamps calm
everybody you know no one really has
time to go to the post office you're
busy you got time for all that traffic
parking who's got time for all that
traffic parking lugging all your mail
and packages it's a real hassle man
that's why you need stamps calm one of
the most popular time-saving tools for
small businesses
stamps.com eliminates trips to the post
office and saves you money with
discounts that you can't even get at the
post office stamps calm brings all the
amazing services of the u.s. post office
right to your computer whether you're in
a small office setting sending invoices
or online or an online sellers shipping
out products or even a warehouse sending
thousands of packages a day stamps.com
can help can handle all of that with
ease right now my listeners can get a
special offer that includes a four week
trial plus free postage and a digital
scale without any long-term commitment
just go to stamps com click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in bird that stamps.com enter
birth alright that was painless huh that
was painless with the reeds over there
so this has been the battle the battle
has been not to for the Battle of the
Bulge here I have to eat well I think we
wrap on August 9th so I'm gonna go hit
the [ __ ] elliptical again and I got to
remember my knee pad I'm at that age now
I got bursitis or whatever in my [ __ ]
left knee and my and my left shoulder my
right shoulder finally feels good that
was the one that was always the problem
with the [ __ ] that rotate we rotated
cuff there whatever the hell you call it
now my right ones all [ __ ] up so I
don't know what to do I remember
thinking like ah you know gettin old
that's just like it's like a mentality
and I just stayed active and I was still
thinking like I'm still running up
flights of stairs I'm almost 50 years
old and then just one day
[ __ ] got the old right there Fred
three out of four of my major joints so
now it's becoming all what the hell I'm
eating I don't know it's the worst I was
reading that Howard Stern thing I was I
was saying that that the article in
Rolling Stone it was this odd
combination of it was like you know
inspiring to see somebody that's trying
to like change and become a new person a
better version of who they used to be or
whatever and then it was also depressing
with just talking about people getting
old and people [ __ ] dying and all of
that [ __ ] just you know I got it well
how do you guys want to go what you got
it you got to pick the [ __ ] dying in
your sleep is the way to go the Iranian
90s you know you had a little cup of
cocoa and a cookie or something like
that right before you went to bed and he
just [ __ ] late you get people when
they get really old super old they're
ready to die you know my grandmother was
like that she lived to almost be 105
years old and she outlived she was she
went through three sets of friends can
you imagine that just think everybody
you knowing loved is dead and then you
get another group of people that you
know and love and then they die and then
you get the third set and they start
dying and if you get that at some point
you have to be sitting there going like
alright am i have vampire this whole
[ __ ] time and I didn't realize it how
many people usually start dropping 60s
and 70s so you live 30 years beyond that
you know you're gonna have to rebuild
the franchise a couple of times here's
another thing to when you die young
people care people show up you get a
great funeral the older you get the less
people that knew you they're gone I'm
trying to think the optimal age to die
like at what point like like a favor
graphing like a great funeral as far as
people giving a [ __ ] cuz you want people
to be devastated when you die right you
want people to just be they're going
through the motions you want people to
be a
emotionally affected but if you outlive
everybody or you live long enough that
all your friends are old that even when
they go up there they have a lifetime of
memories it just gonna be up there like
to fall asleep like [ __ ] that do it on
the Simpsons I would say sometime in
once you get over 70 once you get over
70 I think that that's what you lived
too little too long for a good funeral
you know what I mean as far as people
really caring you know that's when you
start getting to Wow how old was he
75 that's a nice run man I think 75
can't [ __ ] at that you know people
start saying [ __ ] like that you know
anything younger than even the 60s now
people like oh so young 60 you know 67
is dead it's just not a long time like
people need to see that seven once you
get into seven and 80s forget about it
like no one gives a [ __ ] you know 90s
you know I don't know I'm trying to
think like every time somebody dies in
their 90's oh his grandmother died
really yeah she was 91 Oh
91 can't get too upset just grand mother
you can't get too upset about that right
I want that's what the doctor say to you
if you make it into your 90s and you
earn to the hospital and you're on your
deathbed and they're like all right
listen this is it but you know you can't
get too mad at that
I mean 91 you lived in every decade just
think of all this [ __ ] that you saw you
know I mean Christ when you were a
little remember they mean your friend
who got hit with this the rock from the
slingshot [ __ ] dead there's been like
12 presidents since that happened I
don't know what the [ __ ] you're
complaining about like nobody has any
sympathy for you it's like when Bob Hope
died if Bob Hope died like 40 years
before he did if he died in his 60s like
it would have been it would have
borderline been like we when Reagan died
with a parade in his body all over the
[ __ ] country right I mean as far as
what a giant that guy was but he lived
so [ __ ] long
there was nobody left
you know I'm trying to think of great
funerals Elvis had a great one jobless
white caddies Reagan had a great one
Reagan had a better one than Elvis
trying to think of the best funerals as
far as like okay if I'm gonna die and I
want everybody to give a [ __ ] as far as
people giving a [ __ ] oh it does it
there's one for you right top your top
five public figure funerals of all time
I got Elvis Ronald Reagan you see those
are the two that come to mind I only got
two I can't pick a top five it's got to
be an athlete or something right singer
a politician you think Michael Jackson's
would have been bigger Michael Jackson
cuz you know what by then by the time he
died that was like the online response
you don't I mean all these people made
like these dance videos so that was
amazing cuz that came that was like a
round the [ __ ] world reaction so in a
way his was the biggest but like I
didn't see like a lot of maybe it wasn't
like televised I don't I don't [ __ ]
know this is a nice morbid subject to
try to end the podcast on alright well I
think I've done a bottle now this
podcast might be a little bit short but
it is Father's Day today and I got a
hang out with the wife and kid oh and I
got some lines to learn from my scene
tomorrow look at this Rory halfway
through June the shoot is gonna fly by
June is flying by and make sure you get
out there you enjoyed this summer okay
make sure you put on your sunblock by
the way my head's peeling I had to do
this scene outside in the backyard for
the entire [ __ ] day and they were
giving me this umbrella to stand
underneath and it wasn't until the end
of the day that I was kind of thinking
like well this umbrella was designed to
stop rain not block out the [ __ ] Sun
and I cooked my head I didn't overcook
it
alright but it was definitely done the
little Purdue Oven stuff and roaster
that thing popped and it was done and
my head hurt for like three days and now
it's just like
that's gross it's like [ __ ] peelings
it's [ __ ] disgusting so that's what
that was my big Father's Day wish what
do you want for Father's father's day
I'm like aloe vera so I will be staying
out of the Sun thank you to the Westside
comedy club and the Comedy Cellar for
getting me up this weekend I had such a
[ __ ] great time and I'm loving
stand-up more than ever and I'm actually
really enjoying the crowds here in New
York I think I cracked the code I figure
out how to tease them in a way that gets
him out of that stupid you know post me
to hashtag I need to take everything
super seriously at this comedy show and
also to remind them too that they didn't
hire a comic for a private show that
they're adults and they went out to a
nightclub okay okay
it's a [ __ ] relax all right that's it
I don't know who did she are at this
point
hockey's done football's done
basketballs done Go Red Sox kind of the
middle of the pack a little over 500
Yankees are crushing it they don't you
have their regulars yet I know they just
got a big time free agent they always do
[ __ ] right and so I'm gonna be watching
baseball this year to see if the Yankees
can win it this year and they'll have
gone you know they'll have won one in
this decade
keeping this streak alive since the 80s
they want 20s 30s 40s 50 60 70 six
decades in a row six decades in a row
they went over in the 80s now they got
the 90s 2000s and then if they get the
teens they'll be halfway to their record
again it's [ __ ] amazing and look at
the Lakers stocking up like you knew
they would get an Anthony Davis we'll
see how that works out out there I guess
we were possibly in the running but like
I don't know we just we don't play the
free agency game too well we don't do it
as well as the Lakers do you know we did
it well with the big three that's the
one and only time I feel like we really
got it [ __ ] right
but then
I don't know the Kyrie Irving thing
didn't work out I mean he played well
for us we won games and [ __ ] but like at
the end of the day it's all about
winning a championship with us hang I
gotta let people in hey how are you
what's up guys I'm still record how was
dance class was it fun yeah what'd you
do good for you you say Happy Father's
Day Dada yeah thank you very much all
right let me wrap this up and we're
gonna hang it up there you go there you
go all right
that's the that's the podcast here for
this week so yeah so I think um I don't
mean more years do you think LeBron s
it's weird he always seems tired but I
don't know then it comes to the playoffs
and he [ __ ] go if he gets there you
know that's the first time he hasn't
made it obviously in like [ __ ] I
don't know how many years but I think
he's got plenty left in the tank so I'd
say the Lakers are looking pretty good
even though they had a trade away all of
their team I want to see you know I'll
be interesting to see what's going to
happen what about the [ __ ] Warriors
Jesus Christ man they lose KD and then
they keep wanting to call him [ __ ]
Clay Matthews klay Thompson just [ __ ]
to devastating injuries and they might
be out for the entire [ __ ] year it's
unreal it's unreal and then the Lakers
[ __ ] load up and just like that
they're right back in it you know it's
[ __ ] unreal kills me kills me as a
Celtics fan but I got to admit it sucks
when they're bad because Celtics Lakers
is the best [ __ ] you're gonna watch
alright that's it that's the podcast go
[ __ ] yourselves and I'll check in on you
on Wednesday Thursday sorry